[Music]
from the network that brought you
Gilmore Girls Gossip Girl and
girlfriends and the executive producer
of Dawson's Creek comes the CW's attempt
to finally score the boy demographic the
flash when arrow started taking itself
way too seriously it was time to dust
off one of DC's campus heroes for a
spin-off that combines the most
ridiculous stuff in the comics with soap
opera drama when I'm looking into her
eyes it's hard not to think that she's
feeling the same way I do
wacky villains bright colors and
ridiculous sci-fi in a show that really
shouldn't work but somehow ended up
being super fun holy crap my flash man
now I am run faster Barry you run at
that giant shark man meet Barry Allen a
cute 20-something CSI who's somehow in
charge of solving the city's most
gruesome crimes I hope you both skipped
your breakfast but after a convenient
particle accelerator explosion gives him
SuperSpeed he'll use that amazing new
power to constantly complain about not
being fast enough I have to go faster
what about the equation me getting
faster because I want to go faster I
should have been faster you're gonna
help me get faster I'm not getting
faster am I
well no but Barry's not the only young
attractive CW star to get super powers
in that explosion hot new metahumans get
revealed every week and Barry's got help
to track him down
there's adorkable nerd Cisco Ramon who's
cool because he says nerdy things we all
know have you ever seen the frighteners
The Walking Dead Temple of Doom back to
the future terminator Caitlin snow a
doctor's life scientists slash
bioengineers slash hacker slash t
mythologist slash chemist whose primary
job is reminding you her fiance died the
explosion that put you in a coma also
killed my fiance do you know what Ronnie
would say if he was here I already lost
someone I cared about in this building I
can't do it again
Barry's adopted dad Joe a no-nonsense
cop that only cares about one thing
being a terrific dad say like
the best dad ever he just found the best
dad he could have wished for no one
could ever replace you and their mentor
dr. Wells who is clearly a bad guy
welcome miss Smoak who's going to be
lucid dreaming
I did okay so much you put a bail on
this guy I hope we're not enemies come
on he is so evil
I mean look at his eyes the way says
everything want to discuss how or none
of you able to figure this out watch as
Barry struggles against his ultimate
weakness his undying love for his
adopted sister iris a flash obsessed
reporter that can't figure out her
brother's less true love is the flash a
love so strong it can survive anything
even alternate timelines multiple love
interests that would be better for both
of them the fact that they are basically
related and iris answering the question
will they won't they by constantly
making out with this dude in front of it
oh that's rough and again - he's right
there another one man I thought my
sister was me wait thatthat sounded
super weird together these six people
will run Flash's home base STAR Labs
a science center so advanced it can
create anything the plot requires this
is a quantum splicer an anti telepathy
strip so this will allow Cisco to see
into his dream that also doubles as a
secret prison for all the villains who's
STAR Labs was responsible for creating
in the first place
good night
I know they're all bad guys but this
play seems kind of shady right
I mean who feeds all the prisoners or
lets them out to exercise but where do
they pee I don't see any toilets in
those cells guys I mean come on DC this
is one time you actually should have a
pee jar on screen strap in for a fast
moving first season that expertly
balances villains of the week with a
season long storyline that will make you
and Kevin Smith cry like babies then
your helper sees it too that ups the
ante with multiple earths welcome to two
doppelgangers which has happened oh oh
doppelganger alternate timelines you're
not gonna do this time and even more
opportunities to cry like babies I'm
really glad to hear you happy mom oh I
love the show so much
starring air guns
recycle running
Cisco's oral fixation power puns I gotta
run an errand gotta run
how about I give you a lift I will race
over in a heartbeat converse sponsorship
odd cries chores
Pizza daddy issues you're just a kid my
kid I'm not your kid you tell someone
you're gonna be somewhere
you show up guess I didn't have my dad
to teach me that huh and berries
bobblehead but where you have to stop is
the only way Joe what are we gonna do
does that mean no how why I'm telling
you I'm good it's all I've ever wanted
to hear you say try not seeing that
again
Dawson streak I've done a few
calculations you need to consume an
amount equal to roughly 850 tacos wait a
minute he has to eat that many calories
per day Oh
sucks to be the guy that cleans up the
STAR Labs bathroom hey flash fans we are
not done screen junkies is launching an
all-new show Flash and Friends the
screen junkies guide to the arrowverse
call in every week to talk flash
Supergirl arrow and legends of tomorrow
with your host Joe star Roxie's dryer
Jason Hughes and elites worth of special
guests you can check out the first two
episodes free right now on screen
junkies plus featuring all your favorite
DC shows except Gotham is that show
still on be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers thanks again to mafia 3
for sponsoring this episode my name is
Barry Allen and I am the fastest man
alive
bossy boots space pants I am wearing
space pants your mom in a nerd voice hey
what's up just kidding I don't care this
isn't my house and these aren't my pants